hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
this is the second episode on inside
your music
where i look at high-resolution audio
tracks and
examine what's in them and see if we're
getting our money's worth when
i resolution audio
for today's episode i've picked a track
from uh
bmw's download service yes the same
speaker manufacturer but i also have a
download service and when i was
searching for this
music they were the only ones at it
the band is the like poets and the album
is live from the minster
as you can see here is a flack file
format
96 kilowatt sampling 24 bit samples
uh so given 96 kilohertz sampling one
imagines that
it has content all the way up to 48 kilo
sampling
so uh as usual let's go pull this into
uh adobe audition my audio test
application and uh play this track and
uh
see what we see in the uh spectrum
analysis
uh before we get there let's just look
at the amplitude action
uh we see that there's plenty of air in
here
it's not heavily compressed from
loudness
point of view plenty of headroom it's a
live recording
uh so imagine they were careful in in
leaving themselves some headroom towards
the end it gets a little dicey here
i don't know if that's an applaud or
something else
but the music itself is nice and free
from
loudness compression visually examining
it
so let's go ahead and play that and see
what happens in our spectrum display
which has
before starts from zero hertz and goes
up to
half the sampling rate at 48 kilohertz
so right away uh we see a problem
problematic peak in here idle tone
right around 47 kilohertz
as i've explained before i suspect these
are scan rate of
uh computer monitors bleeding into the
analog to digital converter and the
recording chain and there's also one
over here
that's lowering frequency that might be
an ultrasonic
alarm i don't know but neither one of
these obviously is part of
any natural music because we can see the
music has this nice exponential
drop off in here and it has no business
having two pure tones
there are obviously mechanically
generated or electronically generated
let's keep playing
so as the music plays obviously this
beacon is still here and
still problematic but uh we also notice
a secondary problem look at this hump in
here in the noise floor
uh this is typical of some kind of noise
shaping that was going on
uh let me pause this so we can talk
easier
i've got a noise checking that was going
on it's happening right around 22
kilohertz
um some feed in here
you know uh it may be a mix it may be
some
device in the chain is actually running
at much lower sampling rate that was
mixed in with this
um whatever it is it's not natural it's
not good
should have been examined should
eliminate it
uh you know the levels are pretty low at
uh
you know minus uh 90 db or so but
it's still not good
clearly see it in here
um examining how much
actual music content we have we see that
this noise floor also jumps up and down
correlated with the music so we have
this much
uh but right around here i think we uh
drop off as far as usefulness in here um
knowing that a lot of audio that goes
with video uh
is 48 kilo sampling my senses
is that this is really originally from
48
killer sampled digitizer
and this was the you know noise floor as
it sort of went
up in that analog digital converter it
was then up sampled to 96 kilohertz
in the audio workstation for mastering
whatever they did
and then they just released it at 96
kilohertz even though the original
sampling rate possibly had been 48 kilos
so this should really been released as
48 kilohertz
staying true to the original sample rate
as opposed to increasing the sample rate
artificially
what i can't figure out is why this got
in here um
this tells me that it was recorded
something was recorded at
48 kilohertz to have captured this
regardless
we're being fed half the file size is
just total garbage
together with a pure very high frequency
uh
respect to hearing range tone that was
sent out
so another disappointment uh we look in
here we can see these horizontal lines
in here
some traces of them here even well into
the audible band
um any horizontal line as i said is sort
of invariant of music music
never has such deterministic tones in
the pure tones that would show up in
this heat map
as horizontal lines so you know
is is it is this really high resolution
it's better than cd goes above 20
kilohertz but clearly we downloaded a
whole bunch of junk in here and
disappointing that no objective analysis
was done
and sources of these problems identified
and
excuse me workflow uh optimized
uh something i'm gonna add from here on
to tell you that subjectively uh
i just played this music on my main
system and it sounds superb
so you know proof that we don't really
hear all this garbage that's up here
uh and so i don't want to dissuade you
from downloading this track
and and enjoying it just you know if
they have a
choice of lower sample rate that would
be my recommendation to pick
as opposed to uh going with it
okay talk to you guys later in a future
uh
video again this is amir from
audioscience.com
bye-bye